2019年8月30日をもちまして私肇社長
youtube を止めのウソで勝ち月30日をもちまして4個見ればいいんだろうね
僕も教えられて気づいたんでよくわかんないんですけどはじめ殺王のチャンネルが作ら
れたのが2012年の8月30日
チャンネル開設7周年
インテルになりますか
[拍手]
まあをすることで東京で一人なんですけどね寂しいねというわけかそれちょっと
youtube をちゃんとやって7年ですねほんと
応援してくださってありがとうございます去年は6年ってなんかさばいて言ってもう
はや1年7年ですよどうですか
とりあえずはめでたいということですねやばいよね総額1年生だったちっちゃい子が今
中学生の反抗期に入るぐらいですよ7年ってどんなキョロ youtube やってん
だとラベも分かってユーチューバーと言われた時代が懐かしいは入っていいわけですね
まぁちょっと7年でね皆さんにこれまでありがとうございましたっていう
を編んでみたい奴から7年で8本当にありが
がとうございますとこれからもよろしくお願いしますというワイフとまぁ今の心境って
わけではないですけどもうちょっとそういうの話っていこうかなと思いますはい
ちょっとだべっちゃうかもしれないですけどそこは許してください食べれないために何
かちょっとリアクションとってくれべきとこに準備しておいたんであの
今だったらこれでも見ててくださいねよろしくなっ
はいというわけでまあそうですね7年で相当つかの自分で言うのもなんですけどあの
午前以上ちゃんと youtube やってる人ってまずで今ずあると思うんですよね
自分もなんですけど僕以外にもですよ
そう結局何か物事を続ける力ってですね一番大事なことだと思うんで
まあまあ成功する成功しないにしろ男と続ける力っていうのは絶対人生において大切な
ことなんで僕はたまたまそれが youtube でまぁ運が良くみんな
見てもらって席的に続いてるだけなんですけどもまぁ別に何でもいいともうちょっと
続ければ毎日勉強したらそれもテストですよくなるし
ゲーム毎日やってたらめっちゃゲーム上手くなって世界大会で優勝するかもしれないし
て youtube 前に10コツコツと動画だしてたらひょっとしたら
youtube で成功するかもしれないが全部がうまくいくとは絶対言いませんけど
も続ける力がまず第一歩かなと思います揃い
ユーチューバーが少ないですよいま本当にどこを見ても2人組はれ3人組ある4人組6
人組5人組の花人組ならこう人がたくさん集まってでうわぁ数の暴力だなぁって思い
ながら僕は畑つくりましたけどね羽田着は作ったんですけどメインチャンネルは決して
そういうトレンドとかに流されず裏でいろんな人の支えはあるんですけども一人で
やっていこうかなって実家ゲンさんと話していると思いましたという感じで今後もね
経理の瀬街道が買ったりスケールの小さい動画があったりが楕円のためでもなく自分が
したいことだけをやっていくためのチャンネルだと思ってるんでもうそろそうなことが
あったらどんどんやっていこうかなって今後も思っておりますマジでねそう
ユーチューバーほんといないからね女性は月光ソロでやってる方多いと思うんですけど
ね男性
取手ぐゴリゴリやってる人は大体中身なさいねでも基本は再現もグループというか
チームでやってて
人数っていいなと思いますねだからこそ叩きはあの楽しいのかもしれねえ
新たなソロ youtube 上がってるとちょっとねうん嬉しいなと思います
すごい先輩ヅラしてるけどねしょうもねぇ低くって所まで聞くようなんですけども僕の
チャンネルの一番古いどうかって
7年前の動画なんですよもうか素敵という気で多分なんですけど7年前の僕の一番最初
の動画を見るドアの僕すごい恥ずかしいと思うのであえて今日はそれを見てみようと
思いますでは一緒にご覧ください
どうぞここ
の皆さんお疲れさまっ
外れ施設で気もへ疑問よ
見たくないかと思います
メックスチャンネルの
オープニング疑問色々と思うでも部屋もん
希望駅者よねまあなじゃあこれやすいですベックスチャンネルという名前でやってるん
ですよねはいみなさんお気づきだと思うんですけども女だとゆちゃ日焼けするよもう
ギャルみたいなあとなんかに僕名が優しくなったと言われるんですよね
ずに制球しないからね付属さん怒るよの寝不足を繰り返せると二人になっちゃいます
本当にも来たいですよね
気持ち内に彼はこれ
[音楽]
キモーイも駅萌え混ぜてきまー刷新ちゃんねるやってるわけなんですけどねぇ疑問 i
6ミリ温度よりさらにじゃなくて
愛想花束を彼女に増加よメインですね
お台場で消防てね判断神すぎるんだけどくれると思います
まあをご覧いただいたんそうかねぇ
そう最初に消防生涯付き合ってたんですよコンビニの店員さんもやってたんだけどし
ない
これなー
なぜたい動画を出すというスターせ
これから北へねえぞと彫ってるんだやっていくと思う
9 me ん
これからもよろしくです
じゃなくなって思った
パッキーももうやだで音だけをいよう湯をいう
っていうですね youtube に投稿を出すて残るんですよ歴史が黒い歴史が残る
ね皆さんやばまずで本当にまあいいやなんてめっちゃ帰ったんですけど
まああの動画カラーの僕の全てが始まったと言っても過言ではないのであの
大事な思い出ですというわけですね7種に立ったんですけどもうどうしよう
結構やりたいことをガンガンにやり尽くした感があるんですけどまぁそれでも取りたい
動画とかやりたいことは日々だんだん出てくるもんなんですけどまぁ今後も楽しくいっ
てればいいなと思いますもう一度言わせていただくんですけど僕別に誰かを笑顔に
しようとかもうと更紗そんな気ないんで
笑顔にできるに越したことはないんですけどもそれが年から誰かのためにとか面白い
ために笑わせるために動画をやるって言ってるとなんかハードラーがちゃって僕じゃね
やっちゃいそうなんで先にあの何回も yusuke なんか皆さんを笑わせるキー
面白いとか分かる気は毛頭ありません一番大事なのは自分が楽しむこと自分がしたい
ことを動画にすることだと思うんでこんなももしよかったら暇ズルし
程度でいいんであ
警察のチャンネルも今後とも見ていただけるととても嬉しいですよろしくお願いします
では次は初週年目でお会いしましょうそして夏休みがもう終わりそうですナイトプール
はまだいけるのでしょうか
じゃあな
生きてな
[音楽]
me
バッハ